well at least Selena Gomez's hot there
is that getaway which is funny because
that's exactly what you want to do
halfway through this movie so get away
as a car chase kind of movie grade me
fast and furious with one car and one
guy pretty much directed by the director
of the shitty Dungeons & Dragons movies
Ethan Hawke's like the best driver on
the face of the planet but he doesn't
drive professionally anymore because he
burned out he gets this call from this
really menacing voice on the phone which
is clearly Jon Voight you know that
because you see the guy's face from here
down also of Jon Voight
didn't have a really recognizable voice
you would know from his face and the
voice is like we have your wife do
exactly what we say or we're gonna kill
her so drive here and just wreck a bunch
of
then Selena Gomez tries to carjack him
and the voice is like killer and he's
like I'm not kind of killer there I
could bring her with you you're gonna
need her anyway I was like why did you
just say kill it what if he killed her
what it feels like pal there but the
voice be like um you weren't
supposed to do that in any case now we
have our movie in the movie exists to
show you really crazy car chases and
cars crashing in midair at first I was
like alright this movie's awesome that
ain't back 20 minutes into the movie I
was like alright just kind of repetitive
isn't it's like listening to a fun song
on loop for 20 minutes you're like I
could change the song now let's change
the song the movie would have been a
good movie if it had a good script that
was being delivered well but happen to
have car chases in it this is just a car
chase movie that happens to have Ethan
Hawke driving it and Selena Gomez his
face which you're like alright well yeah
she's I think Bieber knew how to take
care of that he didn't know how to take
care of that I'm telling the Ethan Hawke
since she's like I dated Bieber I have
no idea what a man has to offer go Ethan
but really it's just car chases and
wrecking and John voice like wreck
everything he actually tells him that
he's like create as much mayhem as
possible so he just drives through
hot dog carts are flying everywhere cars
are flying everywhere it does look
impressive when cars collide in midair
and spin and do that thing you know the
beach I don't know if you knew it where
I was going but that but I'm a big
burnout fan if I want to see that I can
just play burnout this is like nah why
play and actually experience burnout
when you can just watch burnout that's a
great be version of burnout with a worse
story
burnout has no story you get me and then
the end tries to do this twist thing I'm
not ruining this at all because the
movie goes about it in the stupidest way
possible alright I'm gonna put up a
spoiler warning because I'm about to
talk about what does
at the end of this movie but if you
think to yourself oh it matters it
doesn't matter no it does if you know
who John Voight is it's no spoiler and
you know you do so it doesn't matter the
movie tries to do this saw hello Zep
thing where the wrong guy gets captured
you're like oh that's the bad guy and
then he gets a phone call and John Boyce
there's a oh sorry I got away and Ethan
Hawke's like oh no it would have been
crazy for you too if it clearly wasn't
Jon Voight's voice and Jon Voight's face
it's like imagine in the new Superman
movie Batman gets captured they take off
the mask and at some other guy other
than Ben Affleck and then Ben Affleck
comes around the corner and he gets away
and you're supposed to be like Oh crazy
he got away didn't know but you know
it's not the actor you know that you
know that that's not him cuz you know
what the actor looks like they got some
nobody to be the bad guy in this movie
that it would have worked so no they had
to get Jon Voight in and we'll just not
ruined it based on the lightest form of
entertainment possible it was cool
seeing the chase sequences I could see
the movie being on and then you have a
bunch of friends over and you're doing
something else but this is just on in
the background for ambient noise and
explosions and crashes happening because
you just want ambient noise in the
background and you want a situation
where you can turn and look at the TV at
any given time and you can see a chase
and crashes happening I will say
ironically getaway is a good time if
you're drunk yeah now it's a party way
drunk driving movie I feel like we're
not allowed to say that yes the irony
provokes me to say don't drink and drive
kids be responsible but if you're of
legal age and you're watching this movie
ya can't trash right so your favorite
crazy action driving movie out there
what is it whatever it is comment below
let me know and this weekend from Friday
through Monday I will be at PAX Prime in
Seattle follow me on Twitter I'm gonna
be updating me like hey I'm at this
booth so if you happen to be there and
you want to come say hi say hi a pretty
approachable dude it's always weird when
I get messages and people like I sly in
the mall it didn't say hi say hi fans
are awesome see I'll be tweeting my
location so we can all be creepers
together and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more